what's going on guys so as some of you
know the popularity polls for mikey
academia come out
every year and basically what happens is
in japan
fans of the shonen jump magazine can
kind of like submit who their favorite
characters are for my
academia and then yeah like i said once
a year the votes are tallied up
and typically you know for the last five
years in a row bakugou has been the
number one character
but uh let's see what happens again this
year so basically what i've done
is as you can see on screen there's like
a tier list and i'm gonna just basically
put the characters in order
so i'm gonna start with the character
who came 20th on the list i'm gonna put
them
on the uh on the lowest tier there so
the character who came in at 20th place
was mirko so where is she oh there she
is
yeah so mirko came in at 20th place she
had a
decent year you know i mean she had a
pretty you know i'm not going to go into
spoilers just so people can
you know people who don't read the manga
can watch this video um but i will say
that in the manga
mirko definitely showed herself to be a
very competent hero
uh definitely someone who can uh do the
job no matter what you know no matter
what happens to them
um so yeah she definitely deserves her
place in the top 20.
now the next character who came in at
19th place is someone who had a big role
in season four
and obviously that character is myrio as
you can see on screen
um now after what he did in the overhaul
arc i'm kind of surprised he's not
higher than this
um so we need to get justice for mario
trending because this is a travesty
and my buddhism is better than this for
sure but we'll see what happens next
year you know maybe his fortunes will
improve
moving on to the next character so i
just got to check my notes here to see
who came in
okay so it was tokyomi who came in at
18th place so tokyomi our second
favorite bird boy
um yeah he's had a pretty significant
role in the last year i mean not the
biggest but in terms of being uh
in terms of a student he's done quite a
bit he did it he did a massive thing
that i'm not gonna get into but yeah he
deserves this place in the top 20.
um so after tokyo army we have toga i
like togo a lot she's very
eccentric very unique in terms of her
character i don't know what the results
were last year exactly
but i imagine she was in the top 20 then
as well just because she's you know
she's a fun character
and now in coming in 16th place we got
achako
i think it's fair to say that you know
she is the main female character of this
series
um but in truth you know i'm trying to
think of
major things that she has done in the
manga in this past year
and i'm just blanking a little bit off
top of my head i can't really think of
something big that ochako specifically
has done you know the current art that's
going on it's been going on for the last
year
so basically if you haven't made an
appearance or done anything significant
in this arc
then that will probably affect your
ranking you know on this poll in some
way
so after ochako the next ranked
character who comes in at
15th place is jiro yeah so let's put a
let's go on to the next ranking now yeah
so jiro came in at 15th place she got
over 600 votes in the in the poll which
is a pretty good showing
and as we all know during the cultural
festival jiro had a major
role you know she was telling people
what to do where to go and then she
obviously gave her
wonderful singing performance so um yeah
i would imagine that that boosted her
popularity with a lot of different
people
i i would imagine so now 14th place
is a character i'm sure his popularity
has been decreasing year on year
and someone you maybe correct me on this
but i'm fairly certain every year it
gets lower and lower
just from what i remember uh because as
the story progresses all might becomes
less and
less relevant you know um but yeah all
mike comes in at 14th place
so just ahead of jiro but behind
this guy denki kaminari that's right
to be fair i i like dinky a lot um it
would have been very nice if him and
jira were
were next to each other yeah let's just
do that um but yeah
jiro and denki man it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
i know some people don't like when i
talk about ships um but i gotta say
if there's two ships that i'm i'm sure
will happen one day
number one is deku and achako one day it
just should happen
the way there's been build up there and
i feel the same way with jiro and denki
especially during the war arc
that moment you guys remember it
probably um but i just feel like
that's gonna happen but there are others
that i think could happen as well um but
but i won't go into those
okay so 12th place is momo
yeah momo in 11th we have
present mike i'm very curious as to his
popularity like what is making him
rank so highly above about every
character you know he's in 11th place
that is not a joke that is very good
especially when you're ahead of
characters like
mirko almighty ochaco toga so i'm
really curious about president mike's
appeal in japan
why is he so popular beats me but um
by the way i don't not like him but i'm
just surprised that he's this high
but moving on from president mike the
10th place character so we're
getting into the top 10 now the 10th
place character
is shigaraki and i was surprised that he
was not higher
genuinely like i expected him to be top
five
i thought shiguraki was going to be top
five because he's had a crazy
and not even just the last year like a
year and a half really
you know if we if we take into account
the manga and the anime when he did you
know he did that
he ambushed overhaul i feel like
shiguraki's done enough
to deserve a top five place for sure
because it's a different culture
in japan i'm sure their motivations for
voting for a certain character
would be very different from my
motivations for voting for a certain
character
you know maybe they don't they don't
like him because he's crusty you know he
doesn't have good skin
maybe that's the reason who knows um but
uh yeah sugar comes in at 10th place
and now going into ninth place this is
one that will
definitely shock you it's one that i saw
and i didn't think it made any sort of
sense
but shindo comes in
in ninth place that's right shindo who
i can't even explain this one so he goes
to that other school and it's not
shiketsu high it's a
totally different school i can't
remember which one it was called
but he goes to the school where um that
lady miss joke
you know the one who likes izawa so
she's the teacher shindo is a second
year student there
and in the manga we did actually see
a brief moment of him ages ago it was
just before the war arc started
and it was kind of like a massive spread
of all these different characters you
know miriam was there
bakugo and deku were there eri was there
and shindo was also there
so we got a brief appearance of him in
like december of 2019
i'm pretty sure it was december 2019. we
haven't seen a single thing about him
since
and in the anime it's been years right
been two years since we saw him so this
baffles me this makes no sense
my only logical explanation is that in
japan
this is just my theory but in japan it's
likely
that among all the different ships and
you know when people are talking about
fanfics and ships and all that kind of
stuff i imagine that shindo
must be a popular character in that uh
in you know the fictional stories
because um
that's the only rational explanation you
know he hasn't appeared
forever literally for so long so that's
all i can say that's literally all i can
say
but anyway moving on from this uh from
this crazy
selection of shindo in eighth place we
have endeavour who is a character who's
been
you know improving as a person for a
very long time now um so it's good to
see him you know in the top ten i think
he deserves it
and immediately after endeavor we have
best boy hawks
who if you know if the popularity polls
are up to me he'd be number one
you guys know i love hawks my girlfriend
even called me out for
for her in the video that uh she and i
did together
um but yeah hawks you know willing to go
above and beyond willing to do
things that other heroes cannot do or
will not do so
you know i rate this guy highly happy to
see him in the top 10.
now fifth place isaac now that's a good
choice
that's a good choice so not going into
spoilers but izawa has been the mvp
or one of the mvps of this whole past
year
just all the different stuff he's done
all the different people he's saved
all the sacrifices he's made he is the
goat so
yeah i love izawa i'm happy to see him
in the top five um but with that said
how many characters do we have left we
have five characters
left well that should that shouldn't be
right surely there should be four
characters left
huh oh oh my god guys i made a total
mistake i skipped over hawke i oh my god
this is so embarrassing okay
so aizawa is actually he's still fifth
and hawks is seventh
which means that i skipped someone and
that person
was kiroshima how did i how did i miss
out kiroshima
i literally just skipped over him do i
secretly like
subconsciously not like him i don't know
how i missed him but yeah kiroshima
came in at sixth place so he's above
hawks
but behind izawa so yeah um not
surprising they're not definitely not
surprising like well uh
like what shindo was um so yeah we got
four characters left as it should be um
good thing good thing i realized that
now so fourth place eda now
either is a funny one because i'm fairly
certain that either has always been
popular in japan
and in the last few popularity polls
even when he's not doing much in the
manga or anime he's always been popular
and my theory for that has always been
that kind of like
the target audience for my hero academia
maybe like
sees a lot of themselves in tenure
because i remember that
sir naitai horukoshi said that sir
naitai was meant to be a
caricature of a typical japanese man
and i i feel like this is just my
intuition my gut feeling
but i feel like that same principle for
sir naitai
could be applied to either but for a
typical japanese
teenage boy so i feel like many of the
readers of my hero in japan
relate to tenuita in some way maybe they
act like him maybe they know people who
act like him and they just kind of like
kind of endearing to them i can't you
know all i can say with certainty
is that if we were doing a popularity
poll in
the us or the uk i doubt tenure would be
fourth place
i highly doubt it um so top three i mean
you know
you know you knew it'd be these guys
right deku bakugo and todoroki
but in what order will they come because
like i said
bakuga's been number one for a long time
normally deku's second place
but how is it going to go this year is
it going to be any different
third place on the list is back no i'm
just joking it's todoroki
he's in third place it's not even just
the fans who rate him in third place i
mean in the show itself
deku gets the most attention as the main
character bakugou gets the second most
attention as his main direct rival
and then tony rook is kind of like the
third character who's directly behind
them you know
but for now you know todoroki is still
in third place
so this is the moment of truth this is
it right here
with eight thousand one hundred and
fifteen votes
which is a lot we have deku so deku
comes in
as second place he couldn't do it he
tried
deku did try but he was still over
what is this like over 6 000 votes
behind back ago go
i mean it's a it's going to be hard to
overtake that
you know deku gets the most focus in the
manga so i don't know what more he needs
to overtake back go you know to close
that gap between them
i don't know what he needs but whatever
it is you know he needs to implement it
in the net in the coming year
because even with deku's new
developments you know his uh
his abilities which i will not go into
but you know what i'm talking about
you know even with everything that's
happening he still can't surpass bakugou
so as you would guess you know bakugou
is number one with over
14 000 votes basically 15 000
i mean yeah when i'm looking at these
numbers basically 15 000
um so i mean that's 7 000 votes clear of
deku then
um so honestly this is this is just
crazy the fact that baku goes
this popular it's it's crazy um
at the beginning of the show when i
started watching bakugo was not a
character who indeed himself
to me like i didn't really like bakugou
as time has progressed i've began to
find his character more and more
interesting you know he is definitely
growing that is undeniable
he's definitely growing as a person we
saw it during the um
the remedial course he told that kid you
know you need to learn from your
mistakes you don't look down on other
people
and we can see from then onwards you
know and with developments in the manga
um with him doing things that he
typically wouldn't have done in the past
i think bakago is gonna become a great
hero um so i can definitely see
why his popularity is is so high
um but still though that's six years in
a row he's won
do i think he's been the best character
for six years in a row hell no you know
not six years in a row
but this is what the the people want
this is what the fans of japan like
and uh yeah i'm i'm pretty sure even
harakoshi
is surprised at how popular bakugou is
but uh that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
so thank you guys for watching these
were the top 20 characters
uh officially rated by the um shonen
jump poll
in japan what onto you bakugou stands i
know this is a night to celebrate
um but to everyone else and also to the
back and go stands
peace out